[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public des débats
des experts des reportages chez le
cocktail que je vous propose tous les
soirs à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat et
voici le sommaire de ce 9 novembre La
France est-Elle prête à une guerre à
l'Ukrainienne de haute intensité
Emmanuel Macron a reconnu aujourd'hui à
Toulon qu'il fallait repenser le modèle
futur de notre armée quel budget quelle
place pour la cyberdéfense quelle
puissance et qu'elle responsabilité
européenne l'arme nucléaire ne
donne-t-elle on répond à toutes ces
questions dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat vous le savez
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour on verra comment protéger nos
enfants des images pornographiques sur
internet le gouvernement envisage de
conditionner l'accès au film à la
possession d'une carte bancaire entre la
protection de la vie privée et celle des
mineurs la secrétaire d'État en France a
choisi moi là-dessus j'ai un problème de
valeur entre la santé la santé mentale
psychologique de nos enfants entre les
faits d'infraction sexuelle que sont
parfois qui sont parfois provoqués par
ces images par nos enfants et entre la
liberté d'aller sur des sites
pornographiques et la vie privée des
adultes mon choix est tout fait la
protection des enfants prévaut sur sable
quels sont les moyens déjà existants
pour dissuader les mineurs pourquoi la
justice n'a-t-elle pas encore sanctionné
les sites pornos qui ne respectent pas
la loi réponse dans 45 minutes mais
d'abord donc le président de la
République chef des armées qui tirent
les leçons de la guerre en Ukraine sont
discours résumé par Jérôme Rabier
faire le bilan de nos armées et tenter
de dessiner le futur de la défense un
exercice auquel Emmanuel Macron s'est
plié aujourd'hui depuis la rade de
Toulon le président de la République a
rappelé que la France avait une des
rares armées à pouvoir se déployer
rapidement dans le monde mais qu'il
fallait désormais mieux cibler les
missions comme leur durée actant la fin
de la mission au Sahel dans sa dimension
actuelle nous n'avons en effet pas
vocation à rester engagée sans limite de
temps dans des opérations extérieures
c'est aussi pour cette raison que j'ai
décidé en concertation avec nos
partenaires d'officialiser aujourd'hui
la fin de l'opération barkhane Emmanuel
Macron a également insisté sur un des
marqueurs de l'armée française sa force
de dissuasion nucléaire une sécurité
pour les intérêts stratégiques du pays
mais aussi de toute l'Europe côté
projection dans l'avenir le chef de
l'État et des armées a insisté sur les
évolutions nécessaires avec un fort
accent sur la cyberdéfense mais c'est
aussi sur la guerre de l'information
face aux puissances russes et chinoises
notamment nous ne serons pas les
spectateurs patients de cette évolution
nous devrons savoir la détecter sans
délai l'entraver et un autre tour mais à
la manière d'une démocratie la devancée
en musée à notre profit dans les champs
numériques et physiques
convaincre fait partie clairement des
exigences stratégiques un discours sans
grande annonce le président rappelant
que c'est au Parlement qu'il convient de
concrétiser ses orientations en matière
budgétaire pour la droite sénatoriale il
faudra clairement faire un nouvel effort
l'armée française n'a pas aujourd'hui ni
la dimension ni les périmètres ni le
budget ni les moyens de se projeter de
faire une vraie guerre donc c'est ça
aussi sur la guerre conventionnelle la
question les sénateurs partagent en
revanche la nécessité de se préparer sur
tous les terrains donc les formes
d'armement les formes également
d'engagement la question de la réserve
le rapport avec la nation tout ça sur
une question qui seront à poser et donc
le président a fait un discours très
bien bon tact nous nous allons
maintenant travailler concrètement sur
cette essai de nouvelles lois de
programmation militaire une loi de
programmation militaire qui arrivera en
début d'année prochaine au Parlement et
qui fixera la trajectoire budgétaire en
matière de défense jusqu'en 2030
voilà et pour débattre de l'avenir de
notre défense de notre stratégie de
Défense Gérard Longuet est à nos côtés
bonsoir bienvenue ancien ministre de la
Défense sénateur LR de la Meuse le
général Dominique Trincant bonsoir
bienvenue ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'ONU
Christine Dubois Clément bonsoir vous
aussi chercheuse associé chez risque à
l'Institut d'Administration des
Entreprises et Panthéon Sorbonne Paris 1
et chercheuse au centre de recherche de
l'école des officiers de la Gendarmerie
nationale et Mathieu croissanto
éditorialiste politique à mes côtés
comme chaque mercredi et chaque lundi
bonsoir Mathieu Gérard languette un avis
un peu général sur le discours de du
prénom République est-ce qu'il donne
avec ce discours un nouveau cap
stratégique à notre défense pour être
honnête il est dans son rôle président
de la République et le chef des armées
c'est le cas d'ailleurs sous la
Quatrième et le troisième ce qu'on
oublie
il a il souhaite poser le débat public
nous savons que nous avons
une loi de programmation à préparer pour
le fond l'été prochain et une marque un
certain nombre d'idées mais je partage
le point de vue de votre journaliste pas
beaucoup de noms et il y a d'affichage
d'une sorte de multiplication des
objectifs qui ne traitent pas de la
question essentielle
puisse quelle est notre place dans
l'OTAN et quelle est la défense
européenne que souhaite le président de
la République et qui lui paraît possible
effectivement est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
entre guillemets pardon c'est un peu
trivial mais courir tous ces lièvres à
la fois effectivement en général
trinquant de toute façon la guerre en
Ukraine on l'a déjà évoqué plusieurs
fois sur ce plateau mais il faut le
redire en ouverture de ces débat elle
nous oblige à revoir notre stratégie
bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
revue stratégique qui est en cours dont
le président a parlé de quelques
éléments mais pas de la revue
stratégique globalement qui doit être
rendu pour la fin du mois de décembre
donc de ne devrait pas tarder donc
effectivement il faut en tirer un
certain d'enseignement dans le discours
du Président on il y a deux points qui
apparaissent clairement je dirais même
plutôt trois bien sûr la dissuasion
nucléaire qui est le fondement de la
défense de en particulier des intérêts
vitaux de la France mais aussi le
problème de du cyber et de l'influence
l'influence c'est nouveau on en parlait
pas beaucoup et là on en parle c'est
notre expérience un peu malheureuse il
faut le dire en Afrique qui nous amène
et qui nous conduit à parler de cette
influence expérience malheureusement
l'Afrique mais qu'on lit aujourd'hui à
ce qui se passe en Ukraine en fait
puisque c'est le même adversaire si
j'ose dire qui se présente aussi bien
sur le territoire africain que en
Ukraine c'est la Russie via la milice
Wagner
l'image de la France caricature un petit
peu mais non mais c'est ça
il faut savoir y répondre il faut savoir
même construire le discours avant que
d'être attaqué j'avoue que je trouve que
sur ce plan là on a beaucoup tardé on a
été beaucoup trop réactif et passé
offensif dans ce domaine là Christine ou
un Clément est-ce que c'est un on a bien
compris que c'est une amorce mais est-ce
que c'est un profond changement de
stratégie qui est quand même en train de
s'opérer là sous nos yeux pour la pour
la France alors il y a plusieurs choses
si on parle du côté cyber et
informationsnel puisque en règle
générale on lit un petit peu les deux
dans la mesure où les opérations
informationnelles peuvent utiliser des
moyens des matérialisés multiples alors
il y a les canaux il y a les réseaux
sociaux mais tout cela c'est des choses
qui sont quand même envisagées depuis au
moins 2017 qu'elle est période de la
création du comme cyber et qui ont été
aussi alors de manière progressive et
plus alors si ce n'est timide au moins
en rentrant dans une approche de d'être
de se vouloir défensif et non offensif
par différents textes donc on avait la
lutte informatique défensive la lutte
informatique offensive que l'on a mis
ensuite en place et surtout fin 2021 et
bien la l2i la lutte informelle
informatique d'influence qui avait été
déployée donc on avait déjà ce travail
là l'idée c'est de faire monter en plus
c'est notamment de les faire monter en
puissance la prise de conscience alors
on l'a eu effectivement avec ce qui
s'est passé notamment en Afrique de
l'Ouest avec des reprises
orchestrée par la Russie qui a en règle
générale plus tendance à être
opportuniste et utiliser des conflits
des contextes perturbés qui a créé des
dialectiques mais il y avait au
préalable parce qu'on a pu observer
pendant la crise du covid ou là la
Russie n'était pas le seul acteur
rappelons que la Chine a beaucoup
travaillé sur des méthodes des
informations et même encore avant ça une
des premières prises de conscience ont
été les opérations d'ingérence dans les
élections présidentielles notamment 2016
on y reviendra évidemment sur sur cet
aspect
cyber Gérard quand on dit attention à
pas courir tous les livres à la fois
c'est quoi c'est une question de de
moyen il y a quoi il y a 40 000 hommes
aujourd'hui dans dans l'armée française
c'est ça non non heureusement il y en a
plus mais
sur la mettait on va être à peu près
sans à peu près 70 et 300 000 au total
si vous rajoutez la DGA
le problème c'est quel est votre
adversaire et quel est votre politique
et il est évident que nous avons pu
avoir une armée de qualité parce que
nous avions fait le choix d'une force
d'entrée en
entrée sur le champ d'opération en
premier ce qui est en effet une
particularité française mais sur des
champs qui sont relativement restreint
disons que notre capacité de projection
le contrat c'est aller 20 000 hommes en
permanence à l'extérieur compte tenu du
fait qu'il faut que les autres se
reposent se préparent se forment et que
par ailleurs il y a des missions
constantes
ce que un moment je me dis tiens il y a
une réflexion lorsque le président de la
République avait dit une façon un peu
sauvage un peu cruelle
l'OTAN est en état de mort cérébrale on
sait on s'est rendu compte que si l'OTAN
ne s'est pas réveillé les conflits eux
se sont réveillés et les pays qui sont
membres votre temps comme par exemple
les trois pays baltes et la Pologne et
ceux qui ne le sont pas c'est évidemment
le cas de l'Ukraine ont été confrontés
au caractère tragique de l'histoire et à
ce moment-là on s'aperçoit que tout ce
petit monde se réfugie soulèvent
américaines qui soyons honnêtes pour
l'Ukraine portent l'essentiel de
l'effort de d'aide et donc moi j'aurais
j'attendais c'est là où je suis un peu
frustré j'attendais du président de la
République qui nous disent ok l'Afrique
on fait pas tout et n'importe quoi tout
le temps souvenez de François Hollande à
Bamako le plus beau jour de ma vie oui
d'accord mais une opération militaire
qui n'a pas de projet politique elle n'a
pas de sens si on ne sait pas avec qui
et pour qui on fait la guerre on peut la
faire mais on n'a pas de solution or les
soldats sont là pour détruire des forces
adverse au service d'un projet politique
qui doit être défini la base était on
revient sur l'Europe qu'est-ce qu'il y a
un projet politique européen
manifestement
les pays européens exposés ont fait le
choix d'une sécurité atlantiste la force
de la capacité de projection en homme
Gérard organisé 20000 ça peut être un
peu plus on est on est dans ces deux je
crois que
vous avez raison de souligner le
problème c'est pas tellement de voir 20
000 30
000 c'est de voir comment sont utilisés
ces forces là c'est vrai que d'abord
venons regardons d'où nous venons
pendant 15 ans les budgets de la défense
ont été en dégringolade complète depuis
5 ans les dividendes de la paix
exactement les dividendes de la paix et
les armées ont cherché à préserver leur
capacité effectivement d'entrer en
Poitiers donc d'avoir un échantillonnage
ensuite les opérations ont été
essentiellement au sel guerre
asymétrique j'ai pas besoin de rappeler
que les les djihadistes n'ont pas
d'armes aériennes par exemple donc la
défense aérienne ne comptait pas mais
25 ans le budget est remonté mais pour
réparer une armée et là qu'est-ce qu'on
voit la guerre qu'on croyait impossible
en Europe depuis le 24 février revient
en Europe et dans ce cadre-là et le
rappel de la mort cérébrale de l'OTAN
qui était juste à ce moment-là je
rappelle c'était juste avant la
catastrophe de Kaboul et donc on disait
mais le problème c'est que aujourd'hui
l'OTAN ressuscite merci Monsieur Poutine
c'est Monsieur Poutine qui ressuscite le
temps et tous les pays de l'Est européen
globalement qui se trouve confrontés à
cette menace disent allons dans le temps
et donc la France qui prenait beaucoup
la défense de l'Europe par d'autres
moyens mais ce rallye
naturellement à au point moyen de tous
les Européens faisons ça dans l'OTAN si
un jour les Américains venaient à être
moins
offensif qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui
pensons à l'époque de Monsieur Trump et
bien au moins on aura construit des
outils qui pourraient utiliser par les
Européens mais aujourd'hui c'est
l'urgence c'est à dire qu'il faut
remonter rapidement ça va être l'objet
de la loi de programmation pour arriver
à un niveau de combat qu'on croyait
avoir oublié effectivement alors quand
on parle de quand on commande comme ça
une journée ou Emmanuel Macron s'adresse
aux militaires forcément Mathieu on se
pose la question de ces relations avec
nos armées ça a pas forcément très bien
commencé non non c'est les contrastés
pour ne pas dire compliqué cette
relation et et vous le disiez Thomas
elle a elle a mal commencé avec la crise
ouverte tout le monde s'en souvient des
juillet 2017 par les propos du chef
d'état-major de l'époque le général
Pierre de Villiers sur le budget des
armées alors Emmanuel Macron a été piqué
au vif il avait dit je suis votre chef
aux militaire la veille du défilé il
avait dit ensuite quelques jours plus
tard si quelque chose oppose le chef
d'état-major des armées au président de
la République le Chef d'État des armées
change bref ça va être occasionné
évidemment provoquer la démission de de
Pierre de Villiers sur le fond la
réaction paraissait plutôt logique sur
la en revanche à la froissée quand même
bon nombre de militaires faut rappeler
que Emmanuel Macron n'a pas de lien
particulier avec les armées il a pas
servi sous le drapeau et il a pas fait
son service militaire on va pas lui
reprocher il a pas eu l'occasion de le
faire et puis le service militaire était
supprimé mais tout ça contrairement à ce
prédécesseurs alors depuis il a un peu
il a réveillé avec les soldats chaque
année il a essayé de tisser un lien mais
on voit bien que même si l'endos ce
costume de chef des armées il reste
parfois quelques quelques
incompréhensions quelques crêpes
quiproquo il y en a eu un qui a été
assez fort alors vraisemblablement
instrumentalisé mais c'était vous
souvenez en avril 2021 avec une fameuse
lettre de généraux ou de généreux en
retraite publié par le magazine de leurs
actuelles suivi d'une tribune de
militaire ça ça avait agacé au plus haut
point de Macron vous souvenez il avait
répondu par une image il s'était mis en
cercle lors d'un cérémonie du 8 mai de
du 8 mai avec ses chefs d'état-major
pour montrer en gros que que il y a une
forme de cohésion au fond en discutant
avec les militaires il est respecté
Emmanuel Macron ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il est aimé et alors le
général trinquant en parler il y a la
question du du budget le budget de la
défense il a augmenté en politique et on
dit souvent qu'il y a pas d'amour il y a
que des profs d'amour là pour le coup il
y en a eu des preuves d'amour dans 2023
le budget de la défense il a augmenté
pour la 6e année consécutive le général
trinquant le rappeler en gros depuis
2017 ça a permis de faire passer les
crédits armées de 32,3 milliards à 43,9
et ça va encore augmenter pourquoi alors
pourquoi c'est inédit c'est doublement
inédit d'abord pour vous parler montant
engagé et puis ensuite par le respect de
la parole donnée assez souvent l'État ou
Bercy disait ben on augmente et puis
finalement on rogne là les engagements
ont été tenus d'ailleurs ça fait l'objet
vous le rappeliez d'une loi de
programmation militaire qui s'appelait
précisément réparer et moderniser les
armées alors on verra comment s'appelle
la prochaine qui est en préparation pour
pour toute la période 2024 2030 et donc
cette question budgétaire ça a permis
évidemment d'arrondir les angles on se
parle tenu elle est aujourd'hui reconnue
par par les militaires mais depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine on
en parlait ceci redoute que ça ne
suffise plus et puis en face il y a
quand même au live Scholl ce Camille 100
milliards lui carrément sur la table
pour les pour les armées allemandes même
si il faut le dire ici à la fois les
périmètres et les capacités des forces
de défense allemand non sont pas
comparables avec celles de leurs
homologues français voilà Emmanuel
Macron est porté par une conviction
personnelle qu'il avait mise d'ailleurs
dans son ouvrage programmatique en 2017
c'est que l'armée doit faire son boulot
il disait l'armée n'est pas la modalité
naturelle d'encadrement de la jeunesse
par exemple c'est pas non plus une force
de maintien de l'ordre sur le territoire
sa finalité c'est le combat ben voilà on
y est avec des menaces de plus en plus
fortes de plus en plus nombreuses que
par le passé et là encore pour se faire
sinon aimer au moins respecter madame
Macron va sortir le chéquier alors de
réactions vous vouliez l'un et l'autre
agir pendant la chronique de Mathieu
peut-être donc il craquant c'était si
grave que ça le l'éviction de du chef
d'état-major des armées c'est absolument
pas je rappelle que le général De
Villiers devait partir à la retraite qui
venait qui devait qu'il avait été
prolongé
qu'il a eu ce différent à propos d'un
budget ou permettez-moi de le dire et je
lui ai dit personnellement il s'est
trompé la preuve le budget est arrivé
après il a pas bien apprécié il faut
peut-être rappeler au téléspectateurs
que Emmanuel Macron s'est engagé à faire
progresser ce budget mais que pour
l'année 2017-2018 en tout cas mais non
en fin d'année les finances étaient là
donc Pierre de Villiers c'était trompé
bon c'est une appréciation qu'il a eu il
a décidé de partir alors maintenant je
suis d'accord sur la forme il y a eu un
problème pas sur le fond et c'était le
début du quinquennat rappelons-le donc
il y a eu ces bises billes au départ
mais c'est vrai les preuves d'amour sont
là vous faites bien de le souligner et
aujourd'hui les militaires reconnaissent
que non seulement le budget là mais
comme vous le dites la LPM est respecté
c'est la première fois depuis la loi de
programmation militaire la loi de
programmation militaire pardon et
respecter et ça c'est extraordinaire
l'année prochaine c'est une augmentation
de 3 milliards c'est ce qui était prévu
et c'est ce qui va être appliqué donc ça
c'est quelque chose de très important
mais effectivement il n'y a eu que
réparation on venait de loin et
maintenant il faut engranger quel enfin
il faut enclencher quelque chose d'autre
alors puisqu'on parle budget tiens on va
entendre justement le général Pierre de
de Villiers il était sur BFM TV ce matin
et malgré les annonces notamment les
trois milliards d'euros annoncé il dit
que le compte n'est pas
en 14 aucun des dirigeants ne voulait la
guerre on l'a eu en 39 non plus
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
d'une instabilité mondiale grandissante
il faut en prendre conscience et mettre
les moyens vous savez
quand il y a eu la pandémie on a mis des
centaines de milliards
quand il y a le bouquet carburant mais
des dizaines de milliards
je crois qu'il faut passer à la vitesse
supérieure
alors justement ces chiffres on va y
revenir tout de suite en détail avec
Quentin Calmet bonsoir Quentin donc le
budget des armées 2023 présenté avec ce
chiffre 3 milliards d'euros de hausse
oui c'est ça on va le voir s'afficher ce
chiffre pour le budget 2023 et cette
hausse de 3 milliards en 2023 par
rapport à 2022 soit une hausse de 6%
vous le voyez des crédits au début du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron on
se souvient des tensions que vous
évoquiez notamment avec les sénateurs
aussi de la Commission sur cette
question du la dotation des débuts des
armées mais depuis 5 ans on voit le
budget qui augmente il est passé de 32,3
milliards d'euros en 2019 à 43,9
milliards d'euros en 2023 le ministre
Lecornu qui était auditionné au Sénat il
y a quelques jours qui a rappelé que les
budgets augmentaient face aux nouvelles
tensions sur la scène internationale et
que de nombreux pays suivaient cette
même dynamique mais que la France avait
anticipé dès la loi de programmation
militaire de
2019-2025 dont on termine maintenant
effectivement elle est bien 2025 la date
la promesse atteindre les 50 milliards
d'euros de budget annuel en 2025 soit 2%
du PIB c'est ce que réclamé d'ailleurs
l'OTAN et c'est ce qu'a promis Emmanuel
Macron au début de son premier
quinquennat seul obstacle qui touche
tous les pans de l'économie et donc y
compris les armées écouter le ministre
des Armées Sébastien Lecornu l'inflation
c'est un défi qui s'impose à nous
parlementaire des cartes sur table de
neige oui je pense qu'il faut pas
raconter d'histoires on a une marche à 3
milliards et plus que bienvenue on y
revient pas et que globalement
l'estimation de l'inflation au moment où
on se parle problème de l'inflation
c'est que on en parle au moment où on se
situe c'est globalement un effet d'un
milliard bon alors on l'a dit le
gouvernement travaille sur la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire 2024-2030
mais alors si on rentre un peu dans le
détail de ce budget 2023 qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire et bien il met beaucoup
l'accent sur la question des munitions
c'est ce qu'on a retenu de l'audition
qu'on vient d'entendre dans un extrait
c'était un point d'inquiétude important
pour les sénateurs qu'il avait pointé du
doigt qui sont Cambo le président de la
commission de la défense et des forces
armées avaient donné l'alerte sur ce
point c'était pour lui l'urgence plus
munition plus de missiles plus de
munitions plus de missiles sur ce sujet
Sébastien Lecornu a tenté d'apaiser les
inquiétudes lors de son audition on
écoute un deuxième extrait les munitions
vous disaient c'est 2000 milliards
d'euros que vous nous proposons dans
cette copie pour 2023 c'est-à-dire 500
millions d'euros de plus que sur l'année
2022 c'est clé ça veut dire 60% de
crédit en plus par rapport à 2019 alors
les millions et les milliards ne veulent
pas dire grand-chose si on le dit
autrement c'est comment de 200 missiles
de moyenne portée c'est comment de 100
missiles Center qui par ailleurs font
l'objet d'une actualité livraison de 100
missiles RR Mika bref une liste
importante mais qui vient donner du
concret sur notre capacité à remonter en
puissance sur nos stock de munitions
voilà ça a vraiment occupé une partie
importante de l'audition cette question
des
[Musique]
entraîne à l'heure actuelle il y a
évidemment le volet cyber tout le côté
hybride et la capacité à intervenir dans
tous les terrains hybrides et là il y a
quand même quelque chose qui se qui
boucle avec la question de la loi de
programmation c'est qu'il y a plusieurs
points de tête doit être le 3 le 7 et le
10 qui parlent notamment d'une capacité
de soutenir une économie stratégique
d'avoir une autonomie stratégique donc
quand vous parliez de capacité
d'armement et bien tout ça rentre dans
ce domaine là mais ça veut dire aussi
que il faut ensuite pouvoir travailler
avec les industries de défense pour
pouvoir les réorganiser pour pouvoir
être en capacité non seulement de
produire du stock mais si on devait
arriver dans un conflit de produire du
flux puisque là c'est bien ce que l'on
voit l'Ukraine par exemple qui est dans
une contre-offensive que tout le monde
admire et qui regagne du terrain et bien
est extrêmement dépendante donc du
matériel qui va lui être fourni alors on
parle d'artillerie on parle de système
solaire donc il va viser tous les le
système aérien russe donc on a tous volé
là et il y a un qui est assez
intéressant on voit des pivots qui sont
faits encore une fois dans ces objectifs
stratégiques où on nous explique que et
bien on va faire un pivot puisque on
avait une armée pour de multiples
raisons qui étaient conçu comme étant un
corps beaucoup plus expéditionnel
c'est-à-dire on va faire des opérations
sur le territoire extérieur et pas sur
des guerres de haute intensité et que on
visait pour avoir du matériel de très
grosses technologies potentiellement
très cher mais ne pas avoir énormément
de pièces et là on envisage la
possibilité parfois de ne pas avoir que
du matériel de très haute technicité
mais d'avoir plus de masse donc on est
sur des sujets qui changent un petit peu
parce que finalement il y a quelque
chose qui a bougé c'est la
hiérarchisation des menaces et donc je
vous redonne la parole mais Gérard
Longuet est-ce que moi ce que je retiens
de ça c'est que
c'est un temps long dont on parle
c'est-à-dire si on veut que les
industries français enfin peut-être que
je me trompe mais si on veut que les
industries françaises se mettent en
capacité de à la fois
fournir un stock de munition mais
éventuellement être en capacité de
produire en urgence est-ce que c'est
des choses que l'on peut faire
relativement vite parce que
nos industries d'armement exportent ont
des clients de nature extrêmement
différente et si nous avons en général
mais ça c'est un sujet sur lequel je
vais revenir parce que le président
Macron ou une porte intéressante je
voudrais savoir ce que je ne sais pas
exactement ce qu'il veut aller
pour la France on demande le meilleur on
vend à d'autres des systèmes plus
simples bon or c'est exactement ce qu'a
dit le Emmanuel Macron cet après-midi il
a dit le monde est militaire ne nous
demande pas ou plus exactement que les
industriels ne nous vendent pas
forcément ce qui a de plus technique et
de plus coûteux mais ce qui le plus
utile il a utilisé une autre formule
dont je ne comprends pas très bien le
sens je vais essayer de l'illustrer une
force d'équilibre ça veut dire que s'il
y a un conflit proche de nous qui peut
nous impacter je vais vous prendre deux
exemples la Grèce et la Turquie on n'est
pas passé très loin du conflit
il n'est pas impensable qu'on était
qu'on ait pu être obligé d'être cette
force équilibre c'est-à-dire celle qui
dit en l'occurrence au Turc les gars
calmez-vous parce que les règles nous
ont pas seuls imaginez un seul instant
je vais pas du tout de je fais de la
fiction mais que parmi deux pays
maghrébins nous ayons des relations très
conflictuelles
éclat nous demande de l'aider on ferait
quoi et là on est dans ces conflits à
haute intensité c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
des gros bataillants s'agit plus de
poursuivre en effet des djihadistes dans
le désert c'est vraiment de gros
bataillon avec des gens qui savent
combattre et c'est ce que nous n'avons
pas fait et ce que les États-Unis et
l'Angleterre nous ont demandé de ne pas
faire en Syrie les ruches l'ont fait
mais l'aurions nous fait avec nos moyens
je ne n'en suis pas aussi certains parce
que d'abord la guerre c'est
d'épouvantable il faut quand même se
rappeler une chose et on sait quand on
commence et on ne sait pas comment on
termine donc vous dites
la force d'équilibre c'est une chose qui
a définir et à comprendre ça mériterait
d'être défini parce que si une force
d'équilibre ça consiste à dire il y a
des conflits qui peuvent dégénérer
soyons présents pour éviter qu'il
déjeunait par exemple les choses à la
situation est très simple
l'Europe est protégé par les Ukrainiens
aujourd'hui enfin je parle de l'Europe
de l'Est c'est à dire que les pays
baltes et la Pologne qui ont de bonnes
raisons d'avoir de mauvais souvenirs de
l'Union soviétique et donc de la Russie
alimente mais sans les États-Unis et ça
la Grande-Bretagne l'Ukraine ne pourrait
pas tenir cette situation lorsque le
président de la République parle d'armée
d'équilibre veut-il dire que dans un cas
de ce type nous aurions dû être au-delà
des aller 3 ou 4% qui n'ont présentons
de l'aide et peut-être sans doute moins
en Ukraine alors la guerre à haute
intensité justement on va faire un focus
sur cette question et je vous propose
d'entendre une réaction celle du général
Vincent des portes la question c'est
serions-nous capable de nous défendre
face à la Russie comme le fait l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui voilà ça répond face à la
Russie d'aujourd'hui peut-être face à la
Russie du 24 février probablement pas
nous n'avons pas été préparé pour cette
la France n'a pas demandé à avoir cette
armée là mais nous devons avoir ces
termes-là aujourd'hui la France pour
être clair pourrait tenir dans cette
guerre un front de 80 km alors que le
front en fait 1300 nous dépensons
l'Ukraine dépense en une semaine à
l'artillerie ce que l'industrie
française produit en dix ans on voit
donc que nous ne sommes pas du tout au
niveau où nous devons aller alors vous
n'êtes pas tous forcément d'accord avec
le général dépenses
sur les 80 km permettez-moi de dire que
c'est n'importe quoi les 80 km c'est
quoi dans l'offensive dans la flan garde
dans le la manœuvre d'art d'être triste
dans la menace d'arrêt
bon voilà c'est des abacs qu'un colonel
a lancé parce qu'il faisait des calculs
comme ça
on prend les mesures nécessaires
je pose la question
intéressante c'est on depuis des années
on est les soldats français sont prêt ça
elle par exemple est-ce que ce qu'ils
font au Sahel depuis des années ça les
prépare à cette guerre de haute
intensité dont on parle pas complètement
mais un peu les Césars ont été employés
là-bas et lance-roquettes multiples ont
été employés là-bas nous avions ont été
employés là-bas donc commando ont été
employés là-bas donc oui un peu les
Scorpions les véhicules scorpion ont été
déployés là-bas ont été testés hein donc
ça prépare simplement sur le combat sur
revenir ou que 24 février etc l'armée
française n'a jamais rêvé j'allais dire
de combattre seul contre la Russie
depuis tout le temps c'est dans le cas
d'une alliance j'étais officier
opération du deuxième corps d'armée dans
les années 87 89 donc à l'époque du mur
et de l'empire soviétique à l'époque
nous étions la réserve du groupe d'armée
centre de l'OTAN et on a toujours
travaillé là-dedans et aujourd'hui quels
sont les hypothèses de travail la France
fournit un PC de corps d'armée avec une
division française et une division mult
national et les éléments de corps
d’armée c'est prévu comme ça et ça a
toujours été prévu comme ça donc si vous
voulez les gens qui vous disent est-ce
que la France est capable de combattre
contre la Russie dans ce cas là on ne
l'a jamais calculé comme ça jamais et on
n'est pas en train de le calculer non
plus c'est bien sûr que non c'est
l'objet de ce débat mais bien sûr que
non aujourd'hui dans le cas de l'OTAN
quel est notre place et où allons-nous
et on voit bien qu'on a et on voit bien
qu'on la remplit tout de suite notre
rôle on était la force de réaction
rapide de l'OTAN on s'est déployé en
quelques jours en Roumanie et on a
déployé nos avions au-dessus de la
Pologne on a renforcé l'Estonie c'est ça
notre dispositif donc si vous voulez la
France n'a pas de frontières commune
avec la Russie donc elle est pas dans le
cas de l'Ukraine donc c'est pas la peine
d'inventer des scénarios qui n'existent
pas elle est elle est capable de
participer à bon niveau et quand je dis
ah bon niveau c'est quoi ces numéros 2
actuellement je parle des forces
terrestres c'est niveau 2 derrière les
Américains et les Américains avec
lesquels nous travaillons nous préparent
on se prépare avec eux dans le cadre de
l'OTAN en Pologne en Roumanie et
ailleurs
c'est que les États-Unis d'Amérique de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique détiennent
quand même les clés du fonctionnement de
l'OTAN donc s'il le souhaite nous le
faisons s'ils ne le souhaite pas les
Européens ne sont pas forcément en
mesure de le faire seul est-ce que la
question je trouve les munitions est
intéressante comme sur l'armement est-ce
qu'on est souverain de ce point de vue
là on sait qu'à un moment de la crise
covid on s'est dit il faut fabriquer du
paracétamol il faut fabriquer les
masques est-ce que là qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans le détroit de Taïwan si ça
chauffe on fait quoi nous Français
lorsque le président de la République
dit nous sommes une force équilibre
d'accord mais où et jusqu'où
et en termes de munitions
qui était le fusil qu'on apprenait à
monter à démonter au service militaire
on l'a plus et c'est un fusil allemand
voilà donc
on a comme ça
on revient à l'autre stratégique de
l'Europe de l'Europe de la défense de
l'Europe c'est un effort à faire on ne
l'a pas toujours je vous donne un petit
juste un élément le porte-avion on est
très fier de l'autonomie on a le
porte-avion la catapulte elle est
américaine et la future sera américaine
pourquoi parce que la France a un
porte-avion les Américains en ont 12
donc vous comprenez bien que pour avoir
un élément comme ça c'est là-bas qu'on
va le prendre donc si vous voulez il
faut essayer d'avoir le plus d'éléments
d'autonomie ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
peut avoir complètement de l'autonomie
les gens sera peut-être multiples dont
je parlais à propos de l'utilisation
qu'on en a fait au Sahel et on sait les
high mars comme on les appelle en
Ukraine comme ils sont importants la
France on a c'est un matériel qui est
dérivé d'un matériel américain mais il y
a d'autres matériels qui sont totalement
français comme le César comme le Leclerc
comme les véhicules scorpion les drones
par exemple alors on est très en retard
sur les drones
faut y aller les drones tactiques
aujourd'hui c'est à dire les petits
drones pour l'armée de terre pour
pouvoir faire ça
de plus en plus ça se développe et on a
des drones français pour ça maintenant
les drones qu'on a utilisés par exemple
le Sahel sont des drones répertor
américain parce que le long longue
distance longue durée et ben on a mis
beaucoup de temps les Européens à se
mettre d'accord et à pouvoir qu'elle
construire quelque chose ensemble et au
départ c'était israélien américain en
fait qui était très en pointe allez
j'ouvre un nouveau chapitre dans ce
débat sur la force nucléaire française
quelle puissance et quelle
responsabilité européenne notamment elle
nous donne et je vous propose d'écouter
le président de la République à Toulon
aujourd'hui sur ce thème
aujourd'hui plus encore qu'hier les
intérêts vitaux de la France ont une
dimension européenne
nos forces nucléaires contribuent donc
par leur existence propre à la sécurité
de la France
et de leur
le redire ici est nécessaire
tant les discussions sur ce sujet ce
sont banalisés là où il faut garder la
même sobriété dans la doctrine pour
garder la même crédibilité
mais gardons-nous d'oublier
que la France
a bien la dissuasion nucléaire et
gardons-nous parfois de dramatiser
quelques propos
Gérard Longuet quelle place ça donne à
la France le fait d'avoir la nucléaire
dans l'Union européenne
ça donne au plan international et c'est
consubstantiel à notre position de
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies ça c'est
l'article deuxièmement ça nous place sur
le plan technologique scientifique de
maîtrise des savoir-faire dans une
position d'excellence qui est reconnue
par nos partenaires et qui tire
l'ensemble de notre industrie d'armement
vers le haut bon une fois qu'on a dit ça
le problème de la dissuasion est d'une
grande simplicité c'est pour que ça
marche il faut pas s'en servir et la
question c'est est-ce que ça nous
protège d'une guerre à haute intensité
puisque c'est l'une des protège alors
c'est justement le concept d'intérêt
vital je profondément et il y a des
présidents de la République qui sont
exprimés dessus
pas toujours heureusement
sur le thème
un intérêt vital c'est c'est quoi et ce
qui apparaît dans le sens commun c'est
pas défini dans le sens commun c'est que
le si le territoire français est menacé
d'une submersion totale la réponse est
oui notre intérêt vital et là la
dissuasion devient crédible si on
considère comme intérêt vital la
situation de l'Allemagne pour reprendre
le cas que vous évoquez dans le pourquoi
les l'Allemagne a une attitude assez
réservée vis-à-vis du nucléaire en
général il y a des raisons historiques
je reviens pas il y a surtout le fait
qu'en cas de conflit ils avaient
vocation à être le lieu où on testait la
nécessité d'utiliser ou non la
dissuasion française ce qui n'est pas
très confortable quand vous dites à un
allié et bien nous on va te protéger
surtout si tu es entièrement détruit
alors il préférait qu'on commence avant
et à ce moment là son voisin le polonais
en l'occurrence
la protection française pour l'Allemagne
c'est bien mais nous c'est quoi et
est-ce qu'on quand on va dire aux
Français oui ne m'attendez vous
comprenez sur la Pologne je ne sais pas
moi en ruté ni sur carpatite il y a une
invasion il faut intervenir mourir
pendant 10 ans je veux dire là ça
commence à poser une problème c'est la
raison pour laquelle en matière de
dissuasion je crois qu'il faut rendre
hommage à la technologie l'emploi vous
avez peut-être trahi sur ces sujets
l'emploi m'a toujours posé un problème
et c'est pourquoi je pense que le
on a on n'a pas intérêt à sortir du
concept un peu con de de
d'intérêt vital pas le préciser
Christine ou un Clémence c'est aussi une
autre leçon de cette guerre en Ukraine
alors ça va bien au-delà de la
dissuasion française mais c'est le les
sites nucléaires civils qui ont été
ciblés par l'armée russe il y a eu des
armes entreposées c'est ça dans certains
de ces sites c'est rentrer dans la
stratégie même si c'est évidemment le
contraire une violation du droit
international c'est rentrer dans la
stratégie russe alors en fait ce qu'il y
a eu c'est que la centrale donc civile
de saporidja a été rapidement et
rapidement passé sous contrôle russe et
que effectivement il a été il a été
vérifié que elle avait fait l'objet de
stockage d'armes donc ce qui
effectivement est contraire au droit et
elle a aussi été utilisée comme étant un
moyen de dissuasion en disant attention
si cette centrale et bien est détruite
nous aurons des conséquences etc ce qui
est intéressant c'est que dans le dans
le dans qui se déroule à l'heure
actuelle en Ukraine on parle beaucoup de
conflits de type hybrides c'est-à-dire
qui mobiliserait tout le spectre de la
conflictualité et pas uniquement le
spectre militaire donc on parle beaucoup
du cyber de l'informationnel mais on
pourrait aussi parler de l'économie du
cadre légal donc ce qu'on appelle le
lofer en anglais pour tous ce genre de
tout ce spectre est-ce que l'on a vu
donc vous le disiez c'est une
utilisation d'empreintes civile alors
les Ukrainiens ont parlé d'une
utilisation terroriste quasiment
puisqu'on fait preuve de terreur au cas
où
pour aller sur ce conflit mais il y a
une grande leçon qui a été qui a été
tirée je pense de ses premiers mois de
la guerre c'est que finalement l'Ukraine
dont on admire la résistance a pu le
faire aussi parce qu'elle avait une
population une société civile qui était
extrêmement active et qui s'est impliqué
et pourquoi est-ce que c'est important
parce que quand vous êtes sur des champs
de conflictualité qui ne sont pas
uniquement militaires et bien vous allez
devoir et compter pas uniquement sur des
militaires on parle beaucoup de Laeti
par exemple qui a été cet appel au
volontaire amené par le gouvernement
donc de qui pour que des gens avec des
compétences digitales viennent combattre
on a eu beaucoup d'autres choses qui ont
été mises en oeuvre et qui ont été mises
en place et ce qui est assez intéressant
je pense c'est que donc dans cette dans
cette revue nationale de sécurité cette
ce premier cette première premier jet et
bien on en parle c'est à dire que on
parle de tout ce qui est la résilience
de la nation et d'essayer de renforcer
cette espèce de lien à l'ordre dont on
parle depuis très longtemps
état nation mais que il y a une prise de
conscience intense armée nationale
pour que l'on arrive à avoir cet esprit
de résilience et de capacité de réaction
alors on parle d'augmenter la réserve on
parle de plusieurs choses mais je pense
que ça ça fait partie des choses dont on
s'est aperçu avec le crime mais ça je
trouve ça passionnant parce que
effectivement c'est le terme de
résilience que qu'on met derrière ce
cette idée sauf qu'on en est tellement
loin quoi c'est à dire que la guerre
c'était avant ou c'était ailleurs vous
voyez dans dans l'état d'esprit de ma
génération et de beaucoup d'autres
alors je crois qu'on en est pas si loin
que ça il faut arrêter de s'auto
flageller et de dire que les Français ne
sont pas de bons citoyens ne défendent
pas leur pays etc mais état d'esprit
là aussi la guerre en Ukraine nous
révèle quelque chose c'est que Bernanos
pendant la guerre de 14 disait pourvu
que le derrière tienne en parlant de
l'arrière bon et bien là on voit que la
société
ukrainienne tient le coup et dans cet
aspect résilience mettez-moi de citer un
cas le service national universel les
jeunes les jeunes on a des jeunes
fantastiques en France mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire s'il y a la guerre si
je suis pas soldat qu'est-ce que je peux
faire il y a plein de cas il y a les
pompiers il y a la Croix Rouge il y a
etc et puis il y a les réserves comme
vous le soulignez l'armée la police la
gendarmerie et il faut organiser tout ça
pour l'instant ça reste à améliorer et
donc c'est cette résilience qu'il faut
fortifier en donnant des voix à la
jeunesse pour leur dire voilà ce que
vous pourriez faire si votre pays était
là à la difficulté pas forcément la
guerre catastrophe naturelle également
vous voyez
pourquoi pas établir le service
militaire du coup parce que le service
militaire s'est militaire comme on le
dit ça veut dire que le but c'est de
porter les armes et défendre la
frontière avec les armes est-ce qu'il
faut pas revenir sur cette décision
écoutez moi j'ai toujours commandé des
appels donc on ne peut pas me reprocher
j'ai adoré commander des appelais mais
j'étais aussi dans l'armée anglaise
armée professionnelle et ceci n'a rien à
voir et aujourd'hui notre armée
professionnelle n'a rien à voir avec
Clara l'armée d'appeler qui était je
rappelle à l'époque les Soviétiques
étaient à une étape du Tour de France de
Paris c'est plus le cas maintenant ils
sont quand même assez loin et donc nos
forces elles mènent ce qu'on appelle le
combat de l'avant mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas des tas de choses à faire
pendant que les forces combattent à
en ce moment en Ukraine c'est par
exemple la mobilisation sur les sites
électriques qui sont détruits par les
frapper russe là sont des civils qui
sont qui sont à l'oeuvre alors voilà ça
fait partie de choses qui ont pu être
mise en œuvre et ce qu'il y a à mon avis
et là où ça pose un véritable sujet
c'est comment est-ce que stratégiquement
on intègrerait et bien une action
coordonnée beaucoup plus large et pas
uniquement avec finalement des forces
militaires qui sont habitués à
travailler de cette façon là et c'est un
des gros sujets que l'on voit notamment
avec Lighty Army mais aussi avec ce que
l'on appelle loint l'Open Source
intelligent c'est-à-dire des gens qui
vont vérifier des informations parfois à
titre bénévole ou volontaire en allant
regarder tout ce qui est disponible
notamment en terme d'image sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien c'est comment
est-ce que l'on peut arriver à
coordonner le besoin
la réponse est en tout en gardant et
bien de la confidentialité une stratégie
globale donc ça pose aussi des questions
de gouvernance globale et il y a
énormément de de leçons à attirer de ce
conflit qui se déroule en Ukraine et qui
est encore loin d'être fini Gérard
Longuet on a Mathieu disait rétablir le
service militaire il y a la question de
l'armée de réserve aussi est-ce qu'il
faut la renforcer que sur quel sur quel
pied faut-il danser en quelque sorte
spontanément moi j'étais hostile à
l'idée de enfin la décision du président
Chirac de supprimer le service
militaire ensuite j'ai réfléchi et
lorsque j'ai été nommé mise à la défense
cette réflexion était vraiment complétée
par par l'observation de la réaliser
c'est que depuis enfin depuis 91
c'est-à-dire la dissolution d'une en
soviétique l'idée d'un combat pour
défendre le territoire si tu as une
étape du Tour de France de Strasbourg
est une idée qui a disparu on peut pas
se raconter l'histoire si
à une élection de 2002 il y a eu des tas
de présidentielle depuis 91 quelqu'un
avait dit non mais il faut pouvoir
défendre le territoire en train d'enjeux
russe on l'aurait regardé comme un fou
est-ce qu'on le regarderait toujours
comme un fou aujourd'hui or le service
militaire n'a de sens que si les gens
vont en effet combattre parce que
l'armée générale est plus compétent je
ne le suis je ne le saurai jamais mais
l'armée c'est une discipline qui a du
sens parce qu'il y a un risque c'est le
combat s'il y a pas de combat s'il y a
pas de perspective de combat
c'est une discipline qui est assez
rapidement insupportable surtout dans la
mentalité de la population française
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est garder
une culture militaire et ça les réserves
c'est très très important les traditions
militaires moi je suis très j'étais très
traditionaliste de ce point de vue
communiste parce que il y a plusieurs
façons de combattre et il y a des
histoires militaires il faut les garder
il faut les préserver pour justement
créer ces comportements en revanche et
là où j'attends beaucoup du président de
la République
c'est qu'ils nous disent vers ce qu'il
entend par pays de puissance équilibre
jusqu'où avec qui est-ce que c'est dans
le cadre de l'OTAN systématiquement mais
si je reprends cet exemple de la Grèce
et de la Turquie ce sont deux pays de
l'OTAN on fait quoi avec qui et comment
discutons or on a parlé d'influence on
semble découvrir que la guerre n'est
jamais que la prolongation de la
politique par d'autres moyens ça veut
dire que c'est toujours politique une
guerre vous savez ce qui a le plus
détruit la Résistance française entre
septembre 39 et juin 40 c'est faire
donner la radio de Stuttgart ou un
journaliste français parlait en français
aux militaires français pour leur dire
ce qui se passait dans leur régiment
mais il le disait de Stuttgart ça
toujours existé ensemble découvrir
aujourd'hui les moyens sont plus
importants l'intelligence artificielle
le numérique Internet et ainsi de suite
mais il n'y a pas
engage une guerre c'est très dangereux
conduire une guerre c'est très difficile
s'il n'y a pas de projet politique ça
n'a pas de sens quand Clémenceau a été
nommé en novembre 17 et mon programme
c'est la guerre la guerre la guerre bon
là au moins c'est clair quand elle a dit
était chef de gouvernement en septembre
39 c'est pas les je mobilise mais c'est
pas la guerre bon moyen encore plus
personne ne comprenait rien là la
vocation politique précède le combat des
armées je reviens à la question de
l'armée de réserve une question de
béotien c'est combien de personnes
aujourd'hui qui est concernée alors
aujourd'hui je crois que le chiffre est
de 40000 pour l'armée pour l'armée les
armées alors plus la gendarmerie
il y a la police aussi même mais ces
effectifs ont été augmentés doublés
c'était 20000 c'est passé à 40000 alors
c'est extrêmement important ce qui a de
frappant ce qui me frappe moi c'est le
volontariat exact c'est que on a aucun
problème et on est un des rares pays
d'Europe alors je parle pas des pays qui
se mobilisent maintenant parce qu'il y a
la guerre mais globalement pour avoir
l'armée allemande par exemple à beaucoup
de mal à recruter l'armée britannique a
des difficultés pour recrutées les
bataillants sont à 80% quand on a créé
l'armée de métier on avait les deux
candidats pour un poste aujourd'hui
c'est un pour un mais on a on arrive à
recruter et donc je si vous voulez la
réserve et nécessaire pour des tas de
d'état de tâches et pour compléter je
donnerai un exemple qui est un mauvais
exemple c'est actuellement la Russie qui
mobilise sans avoir rien préparé les 300
000 soldats qui sont mobilisés sont des
fiches c'est tout et donc c'est une
catastrophe donc tout ça ça se prépare
et c'est dans cet esprit là qu'on monte
la réserve je voudrais terminer on l'a
beaucoup évoqué avec vous avec Christine
ou un Clément sur sur cette
cyberdéfense elle a commencé bien avant
le déclenchement de la guerre bien avant
le 24 février elle continue depuis c'est
à dire qu'il y a il y a une cyberguerre
concours dont on parle très peu mais qui
qui continue alors il y en a une ce qui
est assez intéressant c'est que en fait
à parler de guerre hybride on avait
quasiment fini par oublier que la guerre
pouvait être aussi cinétique et faite et
ben de moyens d'artillerie etc la
confrontation qu'on a eu dans le
cyberespace puisque le cyberespace est
un espace de confrontation a démarré
avant donc le 24 février le lancement de
cette opération militaire maximaliste
par la Russie par différents types
d'attaques et on en a encore qui qui
sont en cours de différentes manières on
a beaucoup de déni de services
c'est-à-dire vous avez des saturé un
site internet jusqu'à ce qu'il tombe du
défassement vous allez remplacer l'image
d'un site par un autre ce qu'on appelle
du hackmix c'est-à-dire voler de la
donnée et potentiellement la faire futer
ou la garder pour vous au choix et on a
eu des petits derniers qu'on appelle des
wipers qui sont en gros des logiciels
qui sont de la famille des rançongiciels
les fameux qu'il y avait attaqué les
hôpitaux sauf que et bien ils ont une
petite particularité c'est qu'il
détruisent les données ne demande pas de
rançon et les premiers qui sont apparus
en Ukraine et bien c'était un petit peu
si vous permettez le Canada drive durant
son logiciel c'est à dire qu'ils en
avait tous les aspects sauf que quand
vous vouliez payer et bien vous n'aviez
pas la capacité de payer pour le dire
clairement il n'y avait pas ce qu'on
appelle les Wallet donc ces espèces de
portefeuille électronique qui permettait
de payer en crypto monnaie donc il y a
eu énormément de choses qui ont qui sont
apparues avec à côté de ça et bien une
Ukraine et ça faut pas l'oublier qui est
en guerre notamment dans cet espace de
conflictualité depuis 2014 donc depuis 8
ans donc il y avait quand même eu le
temps de se préparer avec les Américains
qui alertent et qui allèrent aussi la
société civile donc les centres de
réaction et aussi les sociétés de
cybersécurité en disant attention la
conflictualité montre rappelez-vous des
cybers attaques de 2017 wanakry notre
Pékin donc il faut se préparer donc il y
a eu toute une préparation en amont qui
a peut-être limité mais il faut être un
peu prudent parce qu'il peut y avoir des
attaques cyber qui ont été ce qu'on
appelle noyées dans le bruit dont on ne
verra peut-être les effets que plus tard
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'est la fin de ce
débat j'ai rallongé c'est que la guerre
avait commencé avant le 24 février et
que s'il y a une armée c'est parce
qu'elle combat à tort ou à raison parce
qu'il y a les accords de Minsk mais le
combat depuis 8 ans sur le don-basse
merci beaucoup encore une fois à tous et
à bientôt dans ce sens